how about you decide what you want for
your breakfast I've seen a bit Kitty
wink tomato
it was insisted Bandersnatch was
Netflix's first step into interactive
choose your own adventure style content
Netflix saw an opportunity to do
something with their platform that would
have previously been difficult or
impossible to do with film or TV part of
the black mirror series Bandersnatch is
pretty brilliant but it's why
Bandersnatch is brilliant that I think
actually perfectly illustrates why
interactive content might be a dead end
thank you to movie.com for sponsoring
this video choose your own adventure
stories are nothing new they've existed
in books for a long time and video games
have explored interactive narratives
extensively and fairly successfully
there have been attempts to create the
format for film but until now the
technology has always limited how well
that worked
the biggest obstacle when it comes to
film and books is the bandwidth issue
when you give the audience choices to
make you obviously can't give them every
possible choice you have to limit their
choices otherwise your book would be too
huge or your movie would be too long to
even film what's happened
while having a program that possibly
your video games have the distinct
advantage where writing and rendering
multiple storylines is much more
practical but even with these economic
benefits video games can sometimes still
struggle to provide characters with
enough freedom of choice that the player
actually feels in control and like their
decisions matter within the story so
when you limit choice even further than
you would in a video game for a
choose-your-own-adventure film would you
like to talk about what happens with
your mother it can be helpful to revisit
things even if you feel you've done this
before the viewer or player will quickly
start to feel very limited you really
might learn something new so I'll ask
again would you like to talk about what
happened with your mother and what
choices are left out can hold just as
much meaning as which of the available
choices the viewer takes for example
Bandersnatch is strictly binary decision
tree as the viewer this is only an
illusion of choice you don't truly have
any freedom you cannot really guide the
character in any kind of meaningful way
and this becomes quickly obvious the
effect is that it's very difficult to
feel immersed in the character's story
but what Bandersnatch gets right where
it's smart is that it knows this sorry
the irony is that the first piece of
interactive content on Netflix is
already using the meta limitations of
the format to tell its stories the story
explores themes of control limited
choice free will and how reliving the
same events would change things buffer
are the eyeballs will overrun the video
game rate as Aguas price overshot the
video and memory these are all themes
that have relevance to the format or
this is happening to entertain someone
someone who's controlling you where
these elements could be downsides banner
snatch uses them to its advantage when
you want a little more action if you're
watching this now I'm telling ya when
you feel limited by the available
choices of viewer when you feel as if
you're being guided or forced towards a
certain conclusion that only reinforces
what the character is feeling in the
story almost every ending in
Bandersnatch explores these kinds of
themes in some way and even when it
doesn't going back through the film and
finding different paths and endings is
an intended part of the experience if
you do it long enough the details start
to feel jumbled you start to lose touch
with what happened in this watch through
and what didn't you no longer know
what's real in the story which is
exactly the feeling that's driving the
protagonist insane it's what in my
opinion keeps Bandersnatch from being
merely a technical curiosity and it's
the perfect move for a black mirror
story this is also why Bandersnatch
reveals that the interactive format
might be a dead end because the
subversion of the format is the
strongest element of Bandersnatch
without the meta relevance between the
themes of the film and the limitations
of the format it just kind of becomes a
mediocre story the focus becomes
trying to figure out the right
combination of decisions to find
different endings don't get me wrong
that can definitely be fun but I think
the kinds of stories that this format
can be used to tell well is very limited
movies already tell stories well we
don't need to be able to control the
character to tell stories better the
choose-your-own-adventure format adds an
incredible amount of work and writing to
the process I've programmed that path
yet right it's a little pass then yes if
it's going to be like the book so
storytellers must consider is the story
actually better told by the use of this
format because it requires so much
additional work there's little reason to
use the format unless you strongly
believe that's the case unless of course
you're just relying on a gimmick to sell
your story
the limited choice of interactive
content only serves to remind the viewer
that they're watching something
manufactured and limited the different
endings can make it difficult to talk
about with your friends and for critics
to review most of the conversation like
this video ends up being about the meta
aspects of the format and not about the
story itself because which version is
the story Boehner snatch cleverly
overcomes these limitations and uses
them to its advantage but I doubt many
stories will be able to I can imagine
other stories fitting into this format
another Netflix original Russian doll
deals with a Groundhog Day style
repeating storyline a story like that
could be very compelling within the
format because the context for going
back and starting over would be built
into the story but Netflix second step
into interactive content further
supports my suspicions the bear grylls
you versus wild is an interactive take
on his series man vs. wild but the
result is well take your chances with
this line or repel down in and carry on
that way
remember the clock is ticking we've
barely started our journey and in this
jungle heat the medicine will spoil in
less than 24 hours so hurry and decide
which way you want to repel it kind of
becomes an overly simplistic game the
interactive format doesn't really add
anything to the experience of the show
no doubt people will talk about these
future interactive films and watch them
for novelties sake but for now I have a
hard time believing it will be a success
beyond novelty let me know in the
comments what you think do you think
interactive content has a big future as
a genre or do you think it will mostly
fall into obscurity as a novelty thanks
again to movie for sponsoring this video
right now on movie you can watch Errol
Morris's thin blue line along with two
other of his early documentaries the
thin blue line is one of the
foundational true crime documentaries
that pave the way for documentaries like
the jinx and making a murderer you can
watch it along with the 30 other films
that are currently in movies library
when you go to movie comm slash Thomas
flight and sign up for a 30-day free
trial every day movie adds one new movie
and takes one away there's a rotating
library of thirty films I like so much
of what I find and watch on Mubi I think
their curation is really strong and
again you can try for free when you go
to movie comm slash Thomas flight and
sign up for a 30-day free trial go to
movie comm slash Thomas flight for your
extended 30-day free trial thank you for
watching the video thank you especially
to my patreon supporters depending on
the level they give out my patrons get
access to a monthly bonus video a
monthly podcast a discord server and
more you can check it out and decide if
you want to help support my channel at
patreon.com slash Thomas Light
[Music]